新幹線で、
所沢,あ、全然違ったわ
ダークネス井上を、東京の新居に
連れて行こうと思ったんですけども
(泣き叫ぶ)
まぁダメな原因としては
物としては、大きすぎるので新幹線には乗らない
人ではないので
一席分払ってこいつを座席に乗せることもできなかったので
こいつを公共交通機関で、東京まで持ってくるのはほぼ無理だと僕は判断しました
(泣)
(叫ぶ)
(叫ぶ＆叩く)
新幹線は無理、バスも無理
郵送しましょうみたいな話もあったんですけども、
それはダメです。
ダークネスも生きてるので、彼をそんな郵送することはできません。
どうしたら僕はこいつを
何とか東京へ持ってけるのかと考えたところ、
いま朝で、この後すぐ東京に行くんですけども
ヒッチハイクをして、
なんとか！
なんとかこの私と、ダークネス井上を、
東京へ連れてく人がいないかと、信じて！
僕の家から東京までなんとかヒッチハイクをして、誰かに乗せて行ってもらいたいと思います
ちょっと、大事な企画です
無事、届け出ることを願います
頑張ろう！！
静岡から東京への道なりです
もう誰でもいいので、なるべく東京に近づけるように
こう、順番に乗っていければいいなと思っております
なんかいい人がいれば一番いいんですけどね
分りやすいやつがあって、これでうまいこと、この東京まで
連れていってくれればいいなと思っております
俺はこいつに. . .
居場所を与えたい. . .
いくぞ
今日こそは何が何でも絶対に東京に届けます
絶対に東京にとど  あ、ヤバイヤバイ
絶対東京に連れていきます
今から頑張って
このダークネス井上と僕を乗せてくれる車を、ちょっと、待ってみようと思います
ハア　ハア
ウンアアーー
フウ、
止まってくれたんだけど
止まってくれた、止まってくれた
え？
嘘じゃん！！
シルク）何してんすか！
シルク）何してんすか
ハハハハwwww
ンダホ）アーーー
シルク）え？おはようございます
え、おはよ
え！？
え？なんでいんの　なんでいんの？
シルク）　え、用事あってこの辺に
はじめ）　マジでww
シルク）　遠方に行こうと思って
はじめ）　静岡だよw静岡
ンダホ）　え、なんでいんすか
はじめ）　こいつをさあ、東京まで連れて行きたいんだけど、
え、東京に行きたいんだけど、、
シルク）　ああ、でも結局行くんで、
シルク）　その帰りなんで
ンダホ　）そうなんすよ
はじめ）　え、じゃあ乗せてってもらっていい？
シルク）　あ、いいっすよ
はじめ）　マジ！！
はじめ）　やった！！
行きましょー！
はい、というわけで
ンハハハハｗｗ
シルク 　そういうの言うんですねー
え、ﾁｮｯﾄ フィッシャーズが家に来てて、
・・・がたまたま車で来てたので　せっかくの機会と言う事で
ダークネス井上ごと、ちょっと東京に運んでもらってまーす、よー！！
ヨッシ！　よし！
ゆうんだ？
やっぱ、ﾔﾗｾは良くないからね
このまま東京に向かっております。
やめてよ！
うーん、ギャラﾄﾞｽ
ギャラﾄﾞｽじゃない
ありがと、マジで。
いえいえ
ｷﾞｬﾊﾊﾊ
恥ずかしい
行くか
どういう状況なんだ？あれ
参ったねー
参りましたねー
・・・は仕事でお帰りでございます
東京の空気美味しいと思ってますかね？ダークネス
いや、顔色悪いよ
おねがいします
「入っちゃいましょ」
と言う訳で、無事、このまま家に行けそうです
いや、ありがとう、ホントここまで助かったよ、
いえ
気を付けてね
お疲れ様です
おつかれさ・・・
うお”－－－－－－－－－－－－
お”－－－－－－－うお”－－－－あ”－－－
連れて来たぞー
やったーーーーー
と言う訳で無事、ダークネス井上、東京進出、完了しましたー
これで結構ね、解りやすくなると思います
静岡に居る時は、所沢
東京に居る時は、ダークネス
そゆう風にﾁｮｯﾄ観て貰えればわかりやすいかな、と
思います